and you know you're just inviting
trouble because you're broke make a
hundred forty five thousand dollars a
year and you're broke I just discovered
you but I think I'm trying to figure out
is it okay for me to buy this house
March or 2020 so let me let you ask the
questions and I answer are you going to
be dead free by then the only debt I
have Dave is school loans nope until you
get that done but what if I tell what if
we paint the whole picture first before
you say no not going to change I'm not
going to tell you to buy a house while
you have Sallie Mae in a spare bedroom I
wouldn't do that I like you too much to
do that to you will pay it off if it's
not that much how much doing loan debt
have you got 32 okay what's your
household income 145 so why are you not
done by March of 2020 because I'm
thinking about the down payment for the
house and I was going to try to do to
that no we're gonna be debt-free and
then we're gonna come up with as much
down payment as we can what's the March
2020 where did that come from because I
had already signed on to buy this buy a
house in October and I picked out a
different one and so they moved me out
to March
I did hear someone call you and say once
you've given somebody your word you know
what I'm saying like that's where I'm
struggling you didn't start with that
you just said you wanted to buy a house
in March you didn't tell me you'd
already bought a house I thought we were
gonna talk about a little bit more
apologize that's okay so you've already
known I deceive you that's okay you've
already bought a house and you've got a
close on it in March yes okay and how
much is the house 323 G's okay pretty
strong given your income really yeah
really you get that on a 15-year fixed
rates what you're planning on right okay
yep yep so I have never told someone to
break a contract on this show I know
thirty years so I'm not going to tell
you to break a contract you've signed
the contract so it's not really this
discussion is not really relevant you've
already decided what you're gonna do you
already
legally obligated yourself for what
you're gonna do so you're gonna do it
you know but is it what I would have
told you to do no I would not have told
you to do that okay so Kim can ask
another question I'll give you a little
more feedback a little more conversation
on that okay so what I decided to do
would stop my 401 K I was doing 15% I've
got a good chunk in there
I think even if I did it for a you stop
doing it for a year it's not gonna hurt
me that bad about what I was thinking
$400 into that weekly so now I've
started to put that just into savings by
March I could easily have probably close
to 20,000 so that doesn't get me out of
the school loan thing I'll also get a I
get ten thousands and ten thousand
dollars in bonuses every March my house
won't be done until the end of March I'm
just trying to figure out how I can get
this cash Dave you know what I mean but
if you're saying this is too much house
for the amount of money I make that's
where my real concern is okay well run
out of payment with a thirty thousand
dollar down payment at fifteen percent I
mean at 25 percent of your take-home pay
on a 15 year fixed and see if it puts
you in that house okay that's what
that's what our guidelines are and we
tell folks to be debt-free have their
emergency fund in place which you don't
have either hell I do I do
how much is in your emergency fund my
emergency fund currently has 6,000 in it
that's not a fully funded emergency
funds three to six months of expenses
all right correct so I would have you to
be debt-free if I if I could draw this
up with what we teach before you signed
a contract to buy a house we'll have you
to be debt-free can't have the school
loans paid off have saved up your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses which is probably 25 or $30,000
at your house
I'm 145 yet and then and then I would
save the downpayment
so you're about $60,000 premature on
this okay because no emergency fund and
student loans still in place when you
move in and you know you're just
inviting trouble because you're broke
make a hundred forty five thousand
dollars a year and you're broke you're
in debt and you're buying a house and
broke and that's not what we teach
people to do I'm not gonna fuss at you
but you asked what our guidelines are
and what I would do that's what I would
do now what's the doing that you've
signed the contract is I think you're
buying a house you signed a contract